okay when we go ahead get started thank
you all for coming to our weekly device
informatics conference and this week
because the speaker is somewhat
clinically oriented although actually
I'm confident that the entire spectrum
of the program will find his talk
interesting because it touches on all
ask well touch on all aspects of data
around patients but anyways it's so it's
also clinical informatics Grand Rounds
so I'm delighted to welcome my longtime
friend and colleague Chris Longhurst
who is the chief information officer CIO
at University of California San Diego so
a kind of small growing cadre of
physician CIOs and it's it's interesting
to hear the interesting opportunities
that that creates so chris has been all
over the University of California system
he has as did his bachelor's degree at
UC San Diego in molecular biology he
then went up to UC Davis where he went
to medical school and also got a
master's degree in health informatics
from their program he then did his
residency in pediatrics at Stanford and
stayed on at Packard Children's Hospital
where he became CMIO and perhaps
important to many of us want the first
the AC GME accredited fellowship he beat
us out of the gate by a year but that's
great and he was really instrumental in
developing the fellowship programs
and then a couple years ago I guess
almost three years ago now he was
seeking new and more exciting
opportunities and in what was quite a
surprise to me moved back down to San
Diego UC
Diego where he's assumed this CIA role
along the way he's developed a lot of
interests in reuse of clinical data and
I think that's probably what he's going
to focus on today and so I won't take
any further of this time I'll let him
explain it to us although I do as Chris
knows the we're streaming this as we
always do and if any of our folks out
there listening which I know there are
at least several one who send a question
just tweet it with the hashtag D my
scomp DM i seee conf and i'll find a way
to work it in so I will turn it over to
Chris well thank you very much that was
a introduction that would make my mom
proud so it's a pleasure to be here
today I really want to thank dr. Hirsch
for the invitation and it was really a
privilege to meet with the clinical
informatics fellows right beforehand and
I'm glad that you guys could join I am
really passionate about training our
next generation of leaders and starting
to realize that my time is not too long
so I have no conflicts to disclose
irrelevant to today but I'm always
looking for new conflicts if you've got
ideas and I want to start with a bit of
a history lesson so I used to be young I
apparently am no longer young because in
2005 I was a junior faculty member at
Stanford think about where you were in
2005 that was the swearing-in of Bush 42
Brokeback Mountain was a number-one
movie at the box office Peter Jennings
and Pope John Paul a second had just
passed away what was most relevant to me
in 2005 was that shortly after finishing
my training I had agreed to help lead an
EMR implementation more specifically a
CPOE implementation using this vendor
called Cerner and there I was at the
Children's Hospital at Stanford when the
bomb dropped the bomb was the huge paper
that generated discussion across the
country in a little Journal called
Pediatrics this is one of the top 10
cited papers ever in the journal
Pediatrics and the listservs blew up and
you know everybody had something to say
about this paper which is titled
unexpected increase in mortality after
implementation of a commercially sold
concerning CPOE system so childrens
Pittsburgh orhan and Car Co were the
intensivist group there published this
paper and what they showed was that
statistically the implementation of CPOE
in their ICU was associated with an
increase in mortality now this was a
correlation it wasn't a clear causation
but they described in the paper how
their implementation of CPOE was
associated with longer turnaround times
for medications because registration
took longer first couple months of their
system because they've changed process
and policies so that patients that were
being brought into their ICU by critical
care transport on life flight and other
things couldn't actually be registered
until they were physically arrived which
meant that you couldn't order in the
other medications before they arrived
like they used to
well you can imagine children's
Pittsburgh fix this not long after
go-live about two months after go-live
and in fact that's why the authors chose
that three-month period after go-live
because that's where they saw the
statistics significance but in arguably
this highlighted some of the potential
risks and remember this paper came out
right at the time that I had decided in
my career I was going to help lead a
Cerner CPOE implementation at Stanford
so in our intensive this group and the
rest of the faculty in Pediatrics all
read about this we had a lot of
discussions locally we did a lot of
thinking about what it meant and in fact
I got together with our chief quality
officer our then C mio dr. Han and dr.
david claussen and we wrote a letter to
the editor and this was my first
publication was this letter to the
editor where I said you know we read
this with great interest and we think
that it was inadequate preparation
highlighted by these bad policy changes
lack of wireless infrastructure no
critical care
order says that's what contributed
substantially to the increased mortality
rate while we applaud the authors for
highlighting the importance of careful
workflow redesign we caution readers not
to dismiss the importance of the EMR as
a tool to improve quality safety we were
gonna go forward right but I have to
tell you John I wanted to go for it
really really carefully and thoughtfully
and so I've shared with many of you that
one of the things I did at this point is
I started a monthly journal Club that
our electronic health record project
team was obligated to attend and in the
journal club we would review this paper
and others and a lot of the literature
review had come from here at OHSU we
went through the unintended consequences
of electronic health record
implementations in such excruciating
detail I can recite to you all ten of
them now to this day and it really
helped to inform what we thought was a
more evidence-based EMR implementation
which actually is another paper that I'm
not sharing today but after our NGO life
my chief quality officer dr. Shara
called me up and he said dude he's from
Southern California
dude you wouldn't believe this but our
mortality seems to have dropped I was
like whoa and he called me up again at
like 12 months after go-live because he
then you report out to the board and
quarterly increments it's like dude you
wouldn't believe this
I'm like really like yeah it's crazy
18 months kept after go-live he called
me up again is their goal I was oh seven
so this is now like you know early oh
nine and he's like dude I was like what
he's like still dropping and he said
we've got to write this up and so we
wrote up our experience which was that
after our go live comparing 18 months
pre to 18 months post with a simple kind
of statistical comparison and comparing
10 years pre to 18 months post with a
complicated ARIMA auto regressive
integrated moving average which accounts
for seasonal variations and secular
improvements we still saw a
statistically significant decrease in
mortality after a girl live in fact we
wrote in the conclusion sort of bullish
Li the
after our EMR implementation the mean
monthly adjusted mortality risk adjusted
decreased by 20% and based on this data
we estimated over 36 children's lives
might have been saved in that time
period now does that mean that the EMR
saved these kids lives well we all know
correlation does not equal causation I
used to think it did then I took a
statistics class now I don't seems like
the class helped well maybe it was
certainly suggested though in fact um
this paper completed a trilogy of papers
in between those two there was a third
from Seattle Children's and the Seattle
folks found no statistical significance
and their Cerner CPOE implementation but
they wrote really in a very classy way
in their discussion about how much
they've learned from Pittsburgh who
shared their experiences and in fact the
Seattle and Pittsburgh folks both came
to the Stanford go live and so this was
really kind of an experience across the
country on that the Children's Hospital
sign so does that mean Cerner is bad or
is it mean Cerner is good save lives
right or does it mean that you can put
in a system and you can put it in well
or you can put it in poorly I love this
paper by class and in bathes April 2010
where they looked at 62 different adult
hospitals and measured the ability there
in their CPOE systems as implemented to
prevent serious medication safety errors
and what they found here on this really
interesting graph that's done by vendor
is that the top six performing hospitals
right here were all six different
vendors and in fact across any of the
vendors you saw a significant
variability right now I've taken dr.
Claussen out for a couple of beers and
he may have told me you know which one
of these vendors were which but they
blinded it in the paper it's easy to
figure out if there's only one vendor
that that might be a homegrown health
system out of Boston where one of the
co-authors worked but look
the big vendors right you know this
could be like an epic you know a Cerner
and all scripts something like that and
there's tremendous variability which
goes to show the importance of special
people the importance of the team
implementing these systems right
outweighs the vendor choice which
accounted for in this analysis less than
20% of the outcomes so for me that was
really the beginning of the story I was
7 we implemented by 2010 the mortality
paper was out but at the same time over
at the medical school at Stanford Henry
Lowe and Todd Ferris had put together
this really cool research data warehouse
and we were feeding our data in there as
was the adult hospital and that lead for
the next story which is that they built
an anonymous cohort tool very mean I to
be to like and I got really passionate
about the fact that we're putting all
this data in we should be able to get it
out so I was out espousing their cohort
tool to colleagues like my colleague
from residency dr. Jenny Frank ovitch
Jenny had become a pediatric
rheumatologist and she cared for a lot
of patients with diseases like this
right
so what disease is this systemic lupus
erythematosus and she was caring for a
teenage girl who was well known to our
hospital with recurrent lupus flares but
unfortunately one evening got very sick
and I happened to be on the hospital
medicine service she was flown in by
Life Flight actually in the ICU where we
soon transferred her Jenny came in and
asked a really important question she
said this girl's got nephrotic level
proteinuria she's spilling protein in
her urine she's got Hannah phospholipid
antibodies she's got pancreatitis and
hepatitis is she a higher risk for
clotting and should we consider
anticoagulation so we did what any good
evidence-based doctors would do we went
to the literature and how many studies
have been published on teenagers with
lupus in crisis and clotting risk zero
so we did what any good evidence-based
actors would do next we called up our
colleagues for an expert opinion and we
were blessed at Stanford we had five
pediatric rheumatologists and five
pediatric nephrologist and the first one
we asked
said absolutely I would anticoagulate I
had this kid once clotted and no kidding
and the next one we asked said
absolutely not and we were left holding
a bag without any good evidence to help
guide what we should do next so that's
when Jenny did something that had not
been described before she went back to
that cohort tool and she looked up a
similar cohort of 98 patients who were
teenagers with lupus had been treated at
Stanford over the previous several years
she built that cohort using icd-9 codes
at the time for lupus and demographic
data for the teenager right and then on
the day this girl's was admitted to the
hospital she suffered the cohort in a
similar in different patients based on
lab findings and then she looked at
outcomes using keywords in the text like
thrombus and thrombosis blood clot etc
and she was able on the date of
admission to construct an odds ratio
that showed that children like this one
were anywhere from 8 to 15 full higher
risk of developing a clot and based on
that we made the decision to
anticoagulate was that the right
decision the truth is we still don't
know right it wasn't a randomized trial
it was an nf1
what we do know is that in the absence
of good published evidence we use the
data to make the best most data-driven
decision that we could in the
circumstances and if that were my child
or my parent the hospital I would want
their clinicians to have access to that
same sort of thing I will share with you
the rest of the story which is that
after this was published there was a
very tense 48 hours because we actually
put in the end of this two-page New
England Journal article that we made
this clinical decision based on this
data
and that concern was raised that perhaps
this wasn't the right thing to do and
for the tense 24 hours legal
compliance IRB and the Dean had all been
notified at the end of the 24 hours
legal got back to us and said well
there's nothing illegal here and risk
got back and said we think this actually
decreases the risk and this is why
people come back at democratical centers
and compliance came back and they said
well there's nothing from a policy
standpoint that makes us right you were
using you know pH I for operational
purposes the IRB came back and said you
know Jenny had access to look at this
lupus data under an IRB and this wasn't
exactly what this was asked for shame on
you and the Dean who was a pediatric
infectious disease physician I saw in
the unit a few months later I said I'm
really sorry about that whole you know
cluster and he says Chris you're doing
exactly the right thing so this was new
it was different it threatened people
and what does this mean in the evolving
healthcare landscape I want to talk a
little bit about some of the trends that
I'm seeing in my from my vantage point
running an IT department for a large
Health System and medical school and
what that means and the first of course
is that you can't give a talk and
healthcare trends without referring to
precision medicine and a lot of that has
to do with analytics so after the lupus
paper was published people came to us
and said well how would you do that
everywhere what does that look like and
so I sat down with another one of our
informatics at Stanford Nigam Shaw and
our chair of medicine dr. Bob Harrington
and we designed a concept that we called
the green button where in the absence of
published evidence you'd be able to
click a button in the EMR and get a
cohort of similar patients or patients
like mine to help guide decision-making
right now Bob our middle author there is
actually a clinical trial list Bob's
been made famous by the large multi-site
cardiology trials he runs and yet when I
sat down to get to know Bob around our
fellowship program he says you know
everyone thinks of me as a try list I've
published 250 papers and three of them
were the trials you know for the
variable that we randomized for and the
other 247 where observation
all studies based on the data that we
collected in those trials right he says
we've got to figure out how to use this
observational data to help drive faster
improvement in the learning health
system and so we co-authored this with
this concept that when the guideline
wasn't available you'd use the green
button it would automatically find a
large cohort of similar patients and you
could use this practice based evidence
along with professional judgment to
inform your clinical decisions of course
this could be patient facing as well but
an important byproduct of use of this is
that you would then develop that list of
clinical situations for which there
isn't good evidence that should be
prioritized for comparative
effectiveness research and if you truly
built a virtuous learning health cycle
you would then embed that to randomize
at the point of care in the EMR which
sites are now beginning to do right so
that was kind of our vision of a green
button and Nigam and I took a little bit
further working with Blanca and I'm Rico
down in Australia when Blanca came to do
postdoc with us at Stanford and we
described what informatics challenges
would have to be solved in order for
this process to work right first you got
to characterize the index patients so
that's about EHR phenotyping things that
Josh Denny and others at Vanderbilt
country are doing then you have to
quantify patients similarity and that's
really really hard right you probably
need to give tools to the clinician to
be able to change those variables very
easily
you got to optimize your cohort
selection visualize the cohort
appropriately and then control for
confounders or things like high
dimensional propensity scores and then
integrate it with evidence that is 20
years of Informatics research so when
people ask well how come you haven't
built that button yet it's because
there's a lot of unsolved problems that
all need to get solved to build it in an
automated way but in the meantime megohm
and Bob Harrington at Stanford have
started a clinical informatics console
service so they can Mechanical Turk it
because all six steps there were what
Jenny did on the day of admission right
and in fact they've now done over 50
consults at Stanford and the University
of California is
following suit were the second site to
launch of Informatics console service so
that when you have a challenging
diagnostic or therapeutic decision for
which there is clinical equipoise and
not good published evidence you call the
console service and we will generate a
cohort of similar patients to let you
know in our observational data set what
has happened historically to help inform
your decision and of course we're
studying it I'm really excited about
this I think this is really how we build
a learning healthcare system now what is
going to help inform that one of the
reasons that I made the surprising
decision to leave the comfort and
familiarity of the farm in Northern
California for the warm weather in San
Diego is because I wasn't just joining
University of California San Diego I was
joining the University of California
which has six health systems five health
systems and six medical schools so it
was actually my division chief at
Stanford dr. Atul Butte who first left
to go to UCSF and call me up and said
dude we're doing this awesome stuff and
building a data warehouse with data
across all six sites why don't you come
help and I was like I don't know if I
want UCSF he says no no why don't you go
UC San Diego and help and ironically I'm
working more now with the tool than I
did when we were together at Stanford
we're building a UC health data
warehouse and I am the CIO sponsor on
behalf of the six sites we're starting
of course with the phenotypic data from
our epic electronic health records but
our goal is that omics bio banking and
financial and cost accounting and other
data sets to make this really a
world-class resource we made the
decision early on that we would use o
mop as a data structure much like I know
Oh H su is done and others for access
which gives us the ability to leverage
all the Odyssey kind of tool sets for
this as well as lift and shift when it
makes sense so we're early in our
journey on that data warehouse but lots
of things I'll show you in a moment
coming out already so what are the next
important trends that I need to be aware
of as a CIO that we need to be thinking
about as a healthcare enterprise to
sure that we're building the right
solutions well obviously we know
consumerism is affecting the way health
care is delivered and it's no longer
just in the four walls are up here on
the hill in the ivory tower health care
is in the clinics it's in your home and
so I look at these trends together and I
would tell you that your OHSU data looks
very similar to this this graph when I
first saw it at a vendor conference
changed my thinking across the largest
12 largest organizations for one
particular vendor that you use here the
weekly and monthly access by clinicians
and staff in the Health System is
eclipsed by the weekly and monthly
accessed by patients now the workflows
are very different granted right you get
into the patient portal you're there to
look at the results or email your doctor
and you back out whereas your nurse is
in for eight or twelve hours on a shift
and your doctor is complaining about all
the time after hours and things like
that but look at that data and recognize
that the health record is evolving and
it is more the patients now than it is
the health systems at UC San Diego over
a three month period we had 43 percent
of our patients using our patient portal
and that varies dramatically our primary
care is in the 80 percentile and with
that we can do all sorts of really
important things we just had dr. tom
dubenko speaking at UC san diego
yesterday because we're launching not
just on the open notes project but on
the our notes project so this is an all
street journal two days ago I'm really
excited about this because it helps not
just the Triple Aim but the quadrupling
right Don Berwick published the Triple
Aim ten years ago in Health Affairs
article 2008 where he described the the
aim of any healthcare system moving in
the future needed to be three things it
would be delivering high value care at
low cost to a population of patients in
a patient-centered way low cost
patient-centered population health and
for ten years that's kind of what we've
been talking about
until 2014 when Christine's Jansky from
the AMA along with the UCSF faculty
member wrote a really impactful article
in the annals of family medicine called
evolving from the Triple Aim to the
quadruple aim recognizing that you
couldn't achieve those three aims
without caring for the caregiver and
that addressing physician burnout and
physician experience was also important
open notes allowing notes to be read by
patients as OHSU and the community
Portland has done really well helps to
address the patient experience our notes
which allows a patient to self enter
data prior to the visit that
prepopulates the physician note can
reduce the documentation burden of the
doctor by up to 1/3 if you look at Larry
weeds soap note that whole subjective
section is really just me typing what
you're telling me and if you fill that
out as part of your each check-in
process before coming to clinic or on a
tablet in the waiting room not only does
that improve your engagement and our
shared understanding of your goals it
also reduces my documentation burden and
helps to accomplish our quadruple aim do
we know that for sure well it's a
hypothesis and that is a great
opportunity for scholarship for a
enterprise and clinical informatics
fella open scheduling when I moved to
San Diego I asked my wife what do you
want a pediatrician on I'm connected to
the pediatricians we'll find a good one
and she said I want to be able to
schedule on my phone and I said ok but
what kind of quality is he looking for a
pediatrician says I want to be able
schedule appointments not my phone and
in fact you find in Kaiser that it's one
of their main drivers is access to
appointments from their mobile app we've
now rolled out video visits all of these
are based on our patient portal there's
the appointment scheduling and we did
find a practice by the way all the rate
of children's practices allow that
another thing you can do with your
patient portal is you can integrate it
with data from the patient's home and so
we published the first ever
peer-reviewed manuscript about use of
apple health kit when I was at Stanford
when received kamar one of our pediatric
endocrinologist said you know it's such
a pain because we do a lot of phone
management of children of diabetes
every time they call we have no access
to the kilometer and in fact now most of
the patients have evolved a continuous
glucose monitors which create a data
point every five minutes subcutaneous
measurement 288 data points per 24 hours
so how do you get that data oh you know
we asked them to like fax it to us or
like take a picture on a smartphone and
texted oh my god well Apple health kit
was announced in 2013 as part of iOS
something or other and Dexcom who makes
continuous glucose monitors said we're
going to make our product healthcare
compatible and epic said we're gonna
make our patient portal health kit
compatible and so we innovated we didn't
write software we put the pieces of the
puzzle together we worked with Dexcom to
make sure the CGM was working right we
worked with apple on the health kit we
worked with epic on the the health kit
interoperability and we set up in this
paper we described the pilot of 10
patients who were able to automatically
upload their CGM data to the epic
electronic health record and it was a
passive upload in fact most of the
patients described that they forgot it
was happening until they called and the
doctor said oh everybody got your data I
just opened your chart and again we're
helping to accomplish the quadruple aim
because it was a patient satisfier and
it was a physician satisfier because it
reduced a bunch of work but what really
helped us to take off was when Dexcom
said you guys know there's a CPT code
for reviewing continuous glucose monitor
data that can be build up to once
monthly without seeing the patient in
person and our endocrinologist said
really
so we tried dropping a few bills and it
turned out that we were reimbursed by a
commercial payers at a higher rate than
an in-person endocrinology visit and our
endocrinology faculty who had not
initially wanted to adopt regimes you
know a little side project said oh let's
get all of our patients on this because
they could review that data on a monthly
basis provide better care and get paid
for it
Triple Aim so all this talk about
patient portals has been about tether
patient portals
and a question comes up continuously and
dick has been one of the leaders in this
which is what about untether patient
portals
what about interoperable patient health
records right there are people that have
been espousing and predicting that these
would replace tethered patient portals
and I will tell you I used to be one of
them
Paul Tang was on the other side of that
where the great New England Journal
article in 2008 called from the doctors
a to pass to the doctor's office your
your EMR or the Internet and Paul
described that he thought that the
tethered patient record which provides
secure email and appointment scheduling
as well as results review was was the
better path and I said no I'm on the
Google health advisory board and I think
that this new personal health record is
the way to do it cetera so we launched
it we implemented it at Stanford
Children's we exchange data between
Google and our certain area mark we had
over a hundred patients adopted when
Larry Page sunset the Google health
product so we wrote a paper about what
we learned and what we learned from our
patients and this was at a Children's
Hospital that provided tertiary
quaternary care no primary care center
patients back out and community perfect
DK's because we thought people want to
take the record with them and yet what
they told us was what we really want out
of patient portal is to be able to
schedule appointments online and
securely message our clinician and
Google Health didn't do that right so
now 10 years later this was an article
from last summer predicting christening
far that you know secretive team would
build something like that and of course
we now know that UC San Diego was one of
12 health systems that was part of the
iOS 11.3 pilot that allows integration
of data with firebase standards doesn't
require a custom build like Google did
ten years ago and will allow patients to
download data to their own mobile device
so I sat in Apple's headquarters and
they told us you know the details what
this would be and I said I'm having deja
vu because I sat in Silicon Valley ten
years ago on the Google health thing it
seems really similar what do you think
is different and the Apple team said
three things number one
standards and that's true we spent a lot
of money at Stanford trying to pull out
a CCR in a way that was compliant and
have a custom transport protocol to
deliver it to Google and now with fire
standards we just had to turn it on it
was an API at ethics built number two
they said that mobile devices right
Google Health rolled out oh seven the
same year that iPhone was released
things have changed now res computer
their pocket that may be true it's that
number three we think consumerism has
also evolved in that people want their
data more than they did ten years ago so
the answer I think is we will see my own
personal bias is that it is not an
either/or situation that they're
complementary the tethered patient
portal is important for securely
messaging or doctor staying engaged with
your care team for a scheduled
appointments online in the video visits
but having that data in a way that's
accessible can be pulled out and used
because it's your data is also critical
and we're adding the note data through
the open notes project will Apple be
able to develop an ecosystem around apps
and things that take advantage of this
data I don't know Google was not able to
do it ten years ago but I have more
confidence than the team that they've
built at Apple all right
health care value can't give a talk
about health care trends without talking
about health care value right more with
less well I'm talking on some tangential
important things one the clinical
informatics fellows and I were talking a
bit about interoperability I'm going to
put out a very controversial statement I
am going to posit that interoperability
is essentially solved from a technology
standpoint at UC San Diego and at
Stanford we've exchanged data with all
50 US states through the care everywhere
network yes that is just within our
vendor but that vendor touches 50
percent of all adults in the US every
year and now that vendor network here
everywhere is part of care quality which
is actually a network of networks right
Cerner as part of common well has also
joined care quality we're already
exchanging data
between epic and athenahealth and
although very few server sites of yet
signed on with common well and care
quality we're working with some of our
local ones to make that work and that
raises a question which is we have San
Diego health connect which is a local
hie that was funded by an ONC beacon
grant back in 2009 that fifteen million
dollars by the end of their five-year
grant still had not been exchanging data
we've continued to fund that with local
health systems there's some important
process and rules of the road that were
developed about opting out instead of
opting in but the data exchange that's
occurring through this is very limited
compared to what we see occurring
through this and now the standards that
include Social Security and VA as well
so both interoperability is critical
particularly as all institutions
academic medical centers to survive our
affiliating right the era of the
independent doctors practice is
disappearing driven by both high tech
and other health care reform legislation
as well as the evolving culture of
graduating residents who want to join a
group practice and not take call 24/7
and so in San Diego we're seeing this is
that all the practices are joining
either Kaiser or scripts in our region
or UC San Diego or sharp and part of our
strategy of course is affiliating with
them being able to interoperate if they
stay on their athina record or extending
our our Hospital vendor electronic
health record now this has raises
another really interesting question
which is you might have read about our
hepatitis A outbreak which was
unfortunate and driven by some unclean
unsanitary environments and our homeless
population but what was really cool was
that one day the Health System said you
know what we want to reach out to
everybody who hasn't had a Hep A vaccine
or a evidence of titers and bulk message
them that they can come in and place
bulk orders that you know no matter
where they show up working at Moffitt
vaccine and we did it in about five
minutes using a self-service analytics
tool and previously that would have
taken of course a couple weeks of report
writers our CMIO for papel doctoring you
said apatit did this herself took a lot
longer to decide to do that
did actually execute on it and the
reason I bring this up is because it's
creating a new digital divide in 2007
when Google was rolling out Google
Health we talked about the digital
divide in terms of access to the
Internet and things like that now in
2018 there is not much of a digital
divide left right over ninety percent of
adults have smartphones and we find that
lower socioeconomic status have
equivalent access to the Internet
through mobile devices the new digital
divide I believe is the difference
between large institutions like OHSU and
peace health and legacy and Kaiser that
have the resources to invest in their
electronic health record systems and
smaller hospitals like Salem hospital
and rural and safety net hospitals
critical access hospitals and in fact
our friend Julie Adler Milstein who I
know David you just published the paper
with her she's now at UC San Francisco
published this great article identifying
that across safety net hospitals in the
CMS data set they found that their
likelihood to have an EHR implemented
was equivalent as larger hospitals but
their likelihood to actually meet some
of the more advanced criteria for
Meaningful Use was far lower so back to
the beginning remember how we talked
about doesn't matter what vendor you
choose it's the team that's implementing
it well these safety net hospitals they
haven't been able to hire retain pay and
grow the teams they need to effectively
run these systems and so that leads the
last topic which is that we're seeing a
lot of change around health care in the
country through consolidation right
we're seeing mergers acquisitions and
affiliations I spoke with a healthcare
futurist a couple years ago who
predicted that in ten years we would
have 100 or fewer healthcare systems in
the country we're on track if you look
at the pace of M&A over the last couple
of years right so Hsu here has
affiliated with Salem Hospital now what
is the one you're talking about
quality sorry
remember my examples are baddest trying
to localize them but you guys are now
extending your electronic health record
to this smaller affiliate Hospital right
that's what we're going to see I think
more and more in fact one of the
corollaries that I have not heard any
CIO talking about is that as we do this
as we grow in more instances to cover
more hospitals and more communities
oceans now running in 36 US states etc
we're gonna see fewer and fewer health
IT departments and fewer and fewer CIOs
and fewer and fewer CIOs and larger and
larger health IT departments that aren't
just keeping the lights on but are able
to do that sophisticated and advanced
analytics and decision support that are
driving those better outcomes towards
the Triple Aim and the quadruple aim so
I told you I joined the UC health system
right UC San Diego but also UC Irvine
San Francisco LA Davis and our
colleagues at the Office of the
President this is one of those maps that
was generated with data from the UC
health data warehouse that I told you
about at the beginning nobody in the
whole system had ever seen a map of all
of our patients across the five
hospitals before nobody and in fact UC
Irvine there was the last you see it on
a legacy all script system they wanted
to switch to standardized with rest UCS
and instead of going on their own
instance they found that the cost of oil
insertion an instance with UC San Diego
was substantial and so in that process
we've actually migrated our hosting from
on-prem to a cloud hosting model and
we're now also hosting the clinics at UC
Riverside so we have three UCS now
running off of one system we're in the
process of taking our student health
clinic that runs on some niche student
Health System and putting them on our
healthcare or a health system based EMR
as well so we're seeing more and more
growth on something that scales really
well right now the hard work we had to
put in a lot of guiding principles to
make this happen but we're sharing roles
we have a shared CTO across
both UC Irvine UC San Diego and we're
putting together a shared support model
we've actually combined our
infrastructure technology and networking
teams and we're seeing tremendous
benefits from that we couldn't have
afforded at UC San Diego to migrate our
EMR to the cloud on our own
it was the amortization of that cost
with our sister institution that made it
possible and justified the investment
and we're seeing other things like that
as well we've adopted their ServiceNow
platform for our help desk processes our
help desk used to run 8:00 to 5:00 and
evenings and weekends the hospital
operators were answering the help desk
calls you can imagine how well that
worked because we now combined our to
help desks not not geographically nobody
had to move at the call center right but
because we combined them we now run a
24/7 help desk system you know it helped
us with all about volume and and we've
driven down cost and an improved
experience and so I think this is a
really important trend that we're not
hearing talked about a lot but overall
another reason that I went to UC San
Diego besides getting to collaborate
with the other UCS
was this idea that a CIO for both
medical school and the Health System
I could help to pull together the three
missions clinical research and education
and the way that we do that is by
recognizing that the clinical enterprise
and the research enterprise overlap at
an empowered patient population and I
believe this is how we're going to
achieve a learning healthcare system my
friend dr. Chuck Friedman at Michigan
has written some about this where he's
the chair of the department of learning
healthcare systems I will say that I
think there's one really good example of
a learning healthcare system as Tammy
here Tammy now here
NEP well we got a couple pediatricians
in here right then what specialty in
pediatrics do you think has best
accomplished a learning healthcare
environment cancer
what percentage of children with cancer
are on clinical trials 99 percent every
child with cancer right what percentage
of adults with cancer are on trial
less than 5% about 3% of all adults with
cancer right so over the last 30 years
with no new drugs no biologics no sexy
kind of therapeutics cure rates for cute
leukemia have skyrocketed because every
child with cancer regardless of their
outcome is contributing to a learning
environment right and at the same time
97% of our friends and family with
cancer their journey their experience
hasn't contributed to better outcomes
and so really it's our obligation to
determine how we use every patient to
drive better outcomes and the ethics of
this were well described by a guide now
at Stanford Steve Goodman along with the
Hopkins cruise Peter Pronovost Ruth
Faden and Tom in this important article
in the ethics of a learning healthcare
system where they describe that just as
health professionals and organizations
have an obligation to learn patients
have an obligation to contribute to
participate in and otherwise facilitate
learning and that's part of what we
cited and described in that green button
paper because if we're really going to
do this in an effective way we're gonna
have to change some of our policies and
our approach our philosophy and our
ethics and our regulations to allow this
to happen in a way that drives better
outcomes so really it's our goal your
goal over the next 30 years to ensure
that our health care system is learning
from every patient at every visit every
time so thank you very much and we've
got some time for questions thank you so
much for your talk this is wonderful I'm
uh I'm Kristin Stevens
and I'm a MD PhD student in this
department and d-nice and thank you for
making my dream a reality the idea of
doing research on actual patient
populations is like something I've been
like why doesn't this exist the thing
I'm most interested in asking you about
is particularly in your model
um you talked about you brought in a new
player into the patient-physician
relationship and that was the
informatician the person who was you
know you mentioned your consult service
right and that's that position is where
I see like the most potential and also
the most risk regarding this issue that
you brought up of disparities in health
care because ultimately you know the
analyst with the most you know the best
context of the clinical data and and
ability to connect with the medicine and
the population health data and the
patient is going to be like at the crux
of whether you get like a good answer to
whatever your health problem is and how
do you see that like three-way
relationship yeah I think that's a great
question but I would also highlight that
that's not a new problem either is it
yeah so today if you have a rare disease
or a cancer you couldn't google and find
out where the five experts across the
nation are right your local care is not
necessarily going to give you the best
care and so there's some self motivation
there in terms of seeking out you know
the the experts but that's why I bring
up that digital divide and Julia's paper
because I think it is really important
that there's variability and talent we
know talent and people are driving the
outcomes on these systems and the use of
these systems and so to do the right
thing for society at large we're going
to need to build up larger talent pools
the way to do that is going to be larger
you know health IT departments and
systems with not just the single you
know physician representing all doctors
but a team of informatics essence nurses
you know interdisciplinary experts that
can bring their expertise to bear I
don't know if that answers your question
yeah so Richard Gibson health record
banking Alliance so after 30 years and
hundreds of billions of dollars spent on
health records we have the large
dominant physician view is they've heard
our practice and there's no compelling
and and universal or broadly accepted
data that shows that electronic health
records either improve the quality
reliability safety where the cost of
care across all players or a large part
what do you see what is going to take us
to get over that hump so that when we
come back years later and say it was in
this year that there's an inflection
point where the literature or common
experience started to show that EHRs are
worth the tremendous improvement or
worth the tremendous cost both practice
wise and financially great question dick
first of all I want to say I agree with
your assumption there which as you
charge have not delivered a return on
investment they've not delivered on a
product promise that is absolutely
correct in fact we have raised costs of
healthcare because in the era of
financial systems IT RAM two-and-a-half
percent of the operating budget in the
era of automated clinical workflows and
paperless see on our records IT
departments run five six seven percent
of the operating of a hospital that is
money that is being shunted to IT
that has not resulted in efficiencies
elsewhere we still need one nurse for
every four patients or two patients and
the ICU we still need you know people in
the medical records department etc there
are some efficiencies but they're not
paid for us right
so my answer I guess your to your
question will be twofold
one is that this piece here the
healthcare everywhere consumer
empowerment I think that that's where
we're going to get the biggest bang for
our buck we have at UC San Diego a call
pool of other over a hundred and twenty
staff answering the phones like what
turns out like United Airlines has a
smaller cup call pool you know because
we don't push people to scheduling
online because our doctors don't want to
open up their schedules and a million
other reasons I got to do a hem seven
site visit to China where Guangzhou
Women and Children's which is a two
thousand bed hospital with four million
annual outpatient visits does eighty
five percent of their scheduling from
phones by patience right those are
significant efficiencies video visits
and televisions and not having to come
in those will align with changes in the
regulatory reimbursement like you know
more reimbursement for video visits or
bundled care things that incentivize us
not to bring you into clinic those will
deliver ROI so that's my first answer is
the patient piece the second answer is
analytics right we have been on this
journey over the last thirty years from
a research standpoint and institutions
that self developed but really you know
since the Institute of Medicine report
in 2001
crossing the quality chasm and to err is
human described that you know CPOE we
could reduce medication errors a lot of
hospitals begin the journey long before
high tech so we really only have let's
say 15 years 10 years of experience with
it systems have been implemented in a
commercial way and we really haven't
taken advantage of the data right so
everybody's talking about analytics and
we do this at a me and am this and
everything else but I expect we're going
to see some leaps from an analytic
standpoint and I expect that some of
those will come from academics like
ourselves and some of those will come
from industry partners we've seen more
and more being published from Google
Apple's not publishing yet but others
are about introducing sophisticated
analytics whether that's machine
learning and artificial intelligence or
just an easier access to slice and dice
basic data so I think the analytics can
drive some iterative improvements I
think the patient engagement can drive
some really disruptive improvements did
it Hey for online I should introduce
myself yeah okay
Dave door yeah that'd be great
Dave door OHSU professor and vice chair
of clinical informatics so the digital
divide which I've read Julia's paper but
it's been a while I think that is a sort
of the crucial issue and one of the
things that we've taken on as a
strategic game not as strongly as I
wanted to hear it are which su was to
increase the amount of knowledge
generated from the care of patients I
wanted every patient to
at a generalizable knowledge and to use
knowledge in the care of every patient
much like your green button or standards
of care even at OHSU I would argue that
our digital divide for really making
that happen we don't have a Nigam sha to
sort of you know move things forward or
necessarily the resources to do that
what are ways that you think we're going
to be able to tap into larger cohorts or
even the local experience and skill set
here you know we don't have the
authority necessarily to bring everybody
into there yeah what are ways that we
could start to approach this yeah it's a
great question and I agree there's
challenges no no place has every person
and technology to perfectly deliver
these right so I think that the answer
is probably combination I think so that
the first is that you and I have spoken
about the fact that we recently
recruited a clinical research
information officer dr. Mike Hogarth and
Mike as in his cRIO role is jointly
accountable to our CTSA leader for
translational research and to is from an
informatics standpoint and and he's
doing some outstanding work bringing in
the electronic death registration birth
registry to our data warehouse that we
have better and out data quality and
he's actually helping to lead the green
button console program at UC San Diego
because it's really a combined research
you know population health learning
healthcare system kind of project right
he's also uncovering just a lot of basic
blocking and tackling we didn't have in
place so I showed you the map of our
affiliate practices all over San Diego
County but although I was aware of it I
didn't have the time and focus to go fix
an important problem the TNCs right so
when you come to visit UC San Diego
Health System your consent to treatment
identifies that your data may be used in
a de-identified manner for research and
quality improvement guess what our
practice affiliates didn't and so even
though all of the data is in the same
database you know we had that firewall
that for IRB research purposes etc so
he's going back to those practice
is now in a program we're calling
research connect and saying hey part of
the you don't benefit of affiliating
with us is the opportunity to
participate in research don't you want
your patients to do that as well
all the practices are in but it's hard
work of doing that right and at the same
time when we're developing programs like
our informatics console service we'll
make that available to our affiliate
providers that's another benefit of
being part of a large Health System and
even you know the Apple left stuff so
iOS 11.3 will be released here in a few
weeks and anybody who's had care at UC
San Diego and the new iOS will be linked
their medical records and and download
it to their phone our affiliate
practices are not part of that in fact
you'll find their logos in you know the
Apple product when you go in it's not
just UC San Diego it's San Diego sports
medicine the Neurology Center and etc
etc UC Riverside places that wouldn't
been able to afford to do that kind of
innovation but they're benefitting it
from it by being part of the larger
system so III think that I guess a
long-winded answer to short question is
that it's important to get the pot that
processes the policies and the people
aligned and and the the rest of it will
follow so we've talked even among the UC
health team that should we show this
informatics council service is working
we don't need the replicated across
every UC system right we could scale it
at UC San Diego to support all five UC
hospitals using the UC health data
warehouse so they have access to all the
data and in fact I anticipate services
like this are going to expand we're not
going to have the only ones and I would
think that that's going to be the kind
of service that provides a benefit to
your affiliates right your CEO spends a
lot of time and effort thinking about
you know how does this affiliate
relationship work and what services do
we put there what are they getting out
of the relationship and how much money
is it costing us and all that right well
imagine if you can bring some of these
things in as benefits to your affiliate
relationships so so vishnu mohan faculty
here at d- so Chris the question that
that I have is the the case that you
described if the patient with lupus is
really powerful and really I think a
testament
- what you can do with data at the
bedside but this isn't an academic
medical institution where you know the
physician already had access to the data
who knew the value of it who was able to
use the app who understood the the
search terminology and the methodology
to actually get a result my question to
you is how do you see this translating
so that every physician has the skills
to do what this particular physician did
in this case yeah it's a great question
Vishnu and I have a couple of answers to
that first of all that's our job right
we're the informatics we're leaving this
field and it's our job to figure out the
answer to your question secondly it's
our job in an academic Medical Center
environment to drive innovation and to
drive new thinking and new knowledge and
so this idea of how do we take something
was done in a really unique environment
and make it systematically available
that is our job both as informatics and
as academic medical centers right how
are we going to do that well a couple
things one is I describe to you how I
think that you know that there's a
number of problems that need to be
solved to fully automate that but I
believe someday this will be fully
automated I actually believe that
someday this is going to be a service
offered by our electronic health record
vendors that you know somebody using it
can hit the green button and tap into
all the data across clients to get this
kind of thing but I think that service
is 15 or 20 years off in the interim
while we're so solving these problems we
can manually Turk this right with
console services and manual kind of
interventions and I think again that's
our job at academic medical centers is
to help provide those services not just
to ourselves but potentially to the
community as well you have one do you
see so in the model that you sort of
built here the you see sort of the like
physician and patient pair coming to the
informatics team for a consult and I'm
curious to know whether you envision a
place for just the patient to come to
the clinical informatics console because
yeah
great question if you read my green
button paper which I recommend we
actually talk about it in there
I believe that patients need to be
involved every step of the way shared
decision-making some of my favorite
papers have been published in the
journal participatory medicine run by
Danny sands and the Society of
participatory medicine that being said
some of the challenges around getting
the green button off the ground require
a lot of contextual understanding that I
think will be hard to introduce
initially to the patients I think that
the the initial solution is delivered to
the clinicians to use with the patients
and as we solve some of these problems
then we make it available directly to
the patients but it's a great question
and you know that that line between
paternalism and kind of shared
decision-making is an important one I
think sometimes I fall and others fall
on the wrong side of it dr. dot Tom de
Blanca was visiting earlier this week
and he brought a patient with him to
talk about the importance of releasing
those notes and I'll tell you it was so
powerful our entire Department of
Medicine committed to open notes just
because he'd brought the patient and
that made such a statement so Chris I'm
Dionne chase on the nurse practitioner
and Family Practice and also faculty
here at OHSU question for you is as
we're relying more and more on EHR data
to make decisions how do we make sure
the quality is built into that data if
somebody could maybe a data jailer is
gonna curate this data how are we gonna
try and make sure that we don't have
like I'm afraid in my practice a lot of
data that's not necessarily that I could
accurate yeah great question
I got three answers to that first of all
one of the dangers of the green button
if you using that observational data you
start to create a bias in that data
right this is where I saw the best
outcomes so I practiced that way and now
all the data shows that right and so
that's part of the reason it's so
important you have that virtuous cycle
where when there's questions you start
to actually randomize at the point of
care so you can truly understand this
right and that's where I think will go
in the future is more EHR based random
to help conclusively answer some of
these questions
the second is Atul Butte would tell you
I don't worry about the quality of the
data because the volume of the data you
know will wipe out the low quality data
and there's some truth to that right big
data has advantages that I'm you know
even the dirty data kind of gets swept
up in that but there's still biases and
hereand there and so the third answer
and I think the most important I
mentioned with a hepatitis A example the
self-service analytics I am passionate
that our clinicians need to have access
to the data that they've been entering
all this time so one of the classic
informatics you know challenges we talk
about a lot is the problem with the
problem list right Larry we describe the
problem list it's a brilliant idea
nobody uses it right well it turns out
when I introduce the self-service
analytics tool of Children's Hospital
and there was a new drug for treating
cystic fibrosis patients I described
through the the head of the CF Center
hey let's find all your CF patients you
can immediately message them and have
them come in and switch drugs and so we
pulled up the covert like three minutes
at this guy's desktop and then we're
like 50 patients he's like that's not
right there's actually over 500 CF
patients at our institution and I said
that well because you haven't been
documenting on their problem list right
that day he worked with the nurse
practitioner they documented the other
450 and the next day he says to me I've
got all 500 patients now and I can look
at their data or their labs or outcomes
etc so the data quality is affected by
people using the data when you're
putting it in there and as you know
stored never pulled out again I don't
have as much incentive as if I'm now
using this to drive quality improvement
or clinical research in my own practice
or population health outreach right
that's my answer
I'm iclear Eminem the chief health
information officer here somebody is
actually more of a comment back to dicks
comment about the investment we made in
EHRs without seeing a lot of value and I
think there is one huge value that that
we often miss it and it's the
availability and the accessibility of
the information I mean if you think back
to a paper record it's just a
non-starter it's when you you you're all
the information about the visits the
patient's has recently have are always
right there and it's getting better with
care everywhere and everything else and
I you know I think we be we do ourselves
a disservice when we don't point that
out because now that's expected
that's just oh well yeah of course it's
available because it's in it's an
electronic Michael I think that's an
important point you're absolutely right
there are other clear benefits I think
what Dick was describing is that as a
society as a whole we haven't seen the
the ROI from either quality or financial
standpoint but many many papers have
been published about the benefits of
electronic health records of individual
institutions and in fact while
correlation does not equal causation one
of the reasons that we theorized that
the EMR may have contributed to a
decrease in mortality at Packard
Children's Hospital is not because you
know doctors were suddenly practicing
safer if you look at the pittsburgh
paper paper one of the reasons that they
theorized they had a bump in mortality
with the delay in life-saving vasoactive
medications right so we studied and I
published in this paper called
evidence-based EMR implementation how
long it took our life-saving
critical vasoactive medications stat
chest films and and radiology films and
stat one time labs and before or EMR
implementation after all free labs
radiology and medications had
statistically significant improvements
in turnaround times why is that I mean
we didn't give you know methamphetamines
to the pharmacist it was because you
used to write something on a piece of
paper I get to to get lost sat somewhere
etc and now you enter it it's
immediately available practicing in the
neonatal ICU I saw the practice change
you used to write for a chest film send
it off and then go to intubate the baby
because you knew it took 20 minutes for
the tech to come
and immediately after go-live we
realized we couldn't do that because you
put it in there cruising alone and their
wireless cart they were there watching
the intern fail the intubation right and
so there's clearly benefits of
electronic health record just not what
we've expected given the investment
great well I want to thank Chris for an
excellent missionary time
[Applause]